groups of Technology bandits are
targeting Apple stores and a growing
number of grab and run burglaries
thieves hit more than a dozen of the
iconic retail locations in recent months
mostly in California in just seconds
iPhones iPads and laptops are snatched
off the tables and taken out the door
one of the most recent hits was Sunday
in Burlingame California
Mireya Villarreal is outside an Apple
store in Pasadena that was also targeted
Maria good morning wood good morning
this location here was actually hit with
that same type of brazen grab and run
burglary a few years ago now these
robberies actually include thousands of
dollars worth of merchandise in the
recent search is highlighting the
company's security practices or maybe
the lack thereof surveillance video
shows how in just seconds thieves made
off with more than ten thousand dollars
worth of Apple devices this store in Los
Angeles experienced three robberies in
eight days these items are relatively
small and they're very expensive so if
they get away with a few things in their
hands these are very easy to transfer
into cash Apple is notoriously silent
about its security measures but tech
experts believe the real value for
thieves lies in selling the parts a lot
of these gadgets can be $1,000 $2,000 or
more
dan Ackerman is an editor with CNET he
believes Apple has surprises in store
for the thieves people think that you
could run in grab a bunch of stuff in
the Apple Store run out and boom you've
got a bunch of laptops and iPhones not
necessarily the case but it's fairly
well known that they install special
custom versions of the operating systems
on these so there are very limited use
if any if you take them away from the
store another reason for the recent rise
and thefts may be due to apple's lack of
common security features in its stores
like attaching devices to security
tethers and it's not by accident I've
told the teams I'll know we've done a
really really great job if the next
generation of Gen Z says meet me an
Apple Apple's senior vice president of
retail Angela Aaron's told Norah
O'Donnell last year the stores are
designed to be a hangout where customers
can engage with their devices and it may
be worth the risk they seemingly have
decided that it's worth a couple
and grabs Apple feels like if you get a
chance to really play with their gadgets
you might walk out of the store with one
at least one that you legitimately paid
for police are still searching for the
suspects in several of these robberies
including the one from over the weekend
now a spokesperson for the company tells
CBS News they do not comment about their
security practices Gail thank you very
much Maria it's a shame that a couple of
knuckleheads could ruin it for everybody
else I know you just think it's okay to
run in and grab stuff that is yours
because it does show it is one of the
nice experiences about this story I know
you can really go watch everybody check
everything out and it leads to more
purchases at least on my account but
that's exactly right mine too
mijo we thank you again